okay so this is a resume public session
of the planning and development
management committee
um and uh considering the item of 22A
Hope Road just looking to members who
have any questions or wish to comment on
this application please
counselor Welsh
could we consider a deferment to go back
to the applicant with the suggestion
that councilor welcome made earlier
for the reasons that he said I think I
think that there's a there's a
possibility of a compromise
um we want a happy outcome for for
everybody in this application it seems
it seems like a reasonable request
regarded by Council officers
through you chat we we can
um it might be worth asking the
objectives whether they think that would
solve the problem because if it doesn't
then
um we're no further forward
um we
have an incredibly busy June and July
meeting so if there's any chance that if
that compromise could be
um engineered that we could delegate
that decision that would be extremely
helpful in procedural terms
foreign
[Music]
regarding this I was I queried even with
um looking on the uh plans that we were
sent to the the cars as per their uh
parallel to Oak Road I quoted why they
would need to extend the drop curb
anyway because they're not going to have
cars driving over the curb if the
parking Bay is going to be set that way
but on further inspection I also noticed
that he's going out which obviously
cover 24 and 26 is from Windows at about
1.7 meters so at this present time
number 24 and 26 will be looking out
over uh towards the church a car park uh
I'm not in the open space that is there
if we pass this uh application
um the ground floor certainly will look
out of their front window to a wall
which is about five meters 15 foot away
from their front window they will have
no further
uh View and I think that that is a very
big lots of residential amenity and on
backgrounds I will propose that we go
against Opera recommendation and reviews
too much
it's a cancer cancer posing refusal and
um
cancer medicine you indicated that
you'll be managed to refuse so you've
got a second I'm quite happy to Second
councilman is particularly about the
residential immunity rather than
um the needle Community loss of
residential Community with my grounds
for refusal so and I did propose it
earlier
thank you
and Council Thomas suggests that rather
than
um
putting that on a loss of a view which
can't be protected in planning terms
that you refer to loss of Outlook and
and overbearing impact instead I'll take
them words as read yes thank you very
much but very much also simply than I
could thank you
okay thank you councilor minis I just
wanted to confirm in public session what
you said in private that's why so I was
just asking on that
so Council Walsh raised the prospect of
deferral
um
councilor wealth and can I come back to
you to ask you to
um repeat what you said in the private
session about why you think there will
be Merit in deferring this item
uh the Youtube
so are you talking about the rear
boundary the rear boundary which is yeah
so it would still happen you'd still
have the brick wall in front of the cars
in front of the driveway yeah yeah I
understand yeah okay
okay
um councilor Winston I'll come to you
next time uh thank you chair at the more
listen to this debate the more I'm
coming down on the side of
refusing this but there's a big however
here if we refuse this tonight in this
common form then I think I'll be back
here in one or two months time which is
why I'm thinking that the best way to do
this is the the kind of idea proposed by
um councilor Walsh and councilor Welton
there's some compromise position but the
other party is not here so before I make
a decision on that chair if buy or leave
if I can ask the people who are here do
they think if they sat down with the
applicants would they be able to work
out a reasonable compromise
okay just that question
yeah I think I think probably the
question would be
um
Mr Haywood whether you have any idea as
to
whether the owners would be willing to
compromise in the in the way that counts
the Welton suggested so particularly
around the rear boundary not being a
brick wall and whether I suppose whether
that would
ameliorate your concerns or your son's
concerns sufficiently
thank you
okay
yeah understood so I think uh probably
useful to come to Miss Miller or Miss
Coley just for some advice on some of
the things that you mentioned Mr Haywood
and um so I think if we if we if we
deferred in order to explore Council
welton's suggestion
so the the I guess the question is
around the need for the application and
if the um if the owners at 22A the
applicant was willing to do was
counselor wealth and suggested
um what would be the position if they
wanted to build fence his brick walls
further Bender treatments in the future
the permitted development which allows
you to build a fence for a wall is not
just for householders
and so the freeholders could construct
the fence or the wall uh
um if it's non-adjacent to a highway up
to two meters at the moment adjacent to
a highway up to a meter and that is why
we haven't sought to take away permitted
development in relation to fences and
walls because that would be unreasonable
what we have said is that we would take
away permitted development for them to
build out buildings on that land
so that has been removed but as it
stands
the permitted development to construct a
fence along that the rear of that that
grass area already is there
thank you councilor Winston did you want
to
say anything more and uh just speculate
really I think from what you've just
said the the idea of deferring this
future comes a reasonable
um a reasonable accommodation with the
with the applicant
I don't think we can answer that
question tonight can we it will very
much depend on the their reaction okay
thank you
[Music]
yeah it's a trick issue I mean for
myself I having having heard what we've
just heard I
would probably
um be against deferring the item because
I don't think it's going to produce the
compromise that we might be in a way it
would be a meaning misconrivise because
as Miss Mill is just advised um
permitted that development would allow
boundary treatments to be put up at a
later date without without coming to the
committee so or a planning application
being made
um any of them any other members looking
to speak in the house and we've had a
motion to refuse that's been
proposed and seconded
um
I don't think you are seconding the
motion to defer is that all right okay
thank you any other members I could
speak Angela Proctor thank you chair
this is correct me if I'm wrong a
speculative planning application in the
hope that the applicant is successful in
buying the strip of land or buying the
whole corner of the land
they may not be successful anyway
in which case the whole thing's moot but
when I look at the pictures those Flats
have got such
it's open
it's not at all
hemden
and I know we can't use view but we can
use loss of immunity
and it just
it doesn't feel right that
the people in those Flats lose that
Outlook
um that they've got which is is really
pretty
so I'll be voting to reject it thank you
okay thank you Council Proctor any of
the members looking to speak
no
I think for my part I am
I'm concerned by The Proposal because
um I do appreciate the the the impact on
residential amenity from
um
from particularly the Brit wall that
councilor Wilson referred to at the back
which you know is is obviously nearest
to the neighbors and I think
I suppose we've got to deal with the
application that is before us but I
think the development could be done
without having that impact so the owners
could extend the driveway I'd have no
problem with that they could have lower
boundary treatments that perhaps
wouldn't have the same impact on
residential amenity so
um so I am struggling with this one um
but at the moment I'm thinking that I
would disagree with the officer's
recommendation and and refuse this
application
any of the members wanting to speak
before we
moved to vote councilor Welton
uh yeah I think I I agree it's been a
really interesting and useful discussion
I think we've we've had here I was con
um concerned by the lack of a
landscaping proposal you know within
within this obviously I can see that
that's dealt with in the conditions but
I think it would have been really
helpful and useful if we'd actually been
able to see what the
you know what they're proposing what
they're proposing to do I could Envision
I can envisage a you know another
proposal coming forward where they where
these this is then dealt with more
sensitively and I hope that that will be
taking that that will be taken on board
and I
um but I think we you know we we have a
duty to you know to we we've identified
some considerable harm I think to uh
um
to the residents and
um and I think that we you know we're
within our rights to to
go against
um
the recommendation to uphold those yes
that's uh you know the right to not for
not that harm not to be done to them
shall we say so yes I will I will also
uh agree with the proposal
okay thank you councilman
um any members looking to
speak in favor of Grant I'll propose any
motion to that effect
no okay has been moved and seconded that
we uh refuse plan of permission
contrary to the office's recommendation
and I think her reason for refusal we
uh well we certainly discussed in a
private session which is um loss of
residential amenity
um particularly with regard to Resonance
with protective characteristics okay
thank you so we'll um
we'll vote on that motion to refuse then
if we could so all those in favor
refusing if you could indicate now
okay that is unanimous so that
application is refused
thank you very much Mr Hayward and for
coming to speak to us appreciate it
thank you
okay members will uh move on now to the
uh
next application uh
which will be uh homely 21 still Fox
Avenue's application
109.074 and we will start this item with
an introduction from Miss Miller thank
you
thank you chair this application with
two stories summary
the application proposes the direction
of a two-story side and rear extension a
front porch a conversion of the laugh to
habitable space and the demolition of a
freestanding garage
the application is reported as the
planning committee as it's been called
in by councilor for us two objections
were received from the neighboring
properties at number 19 and 23. their
main concerns relate to the scale of the
proposal and the impact on residential
amenity and the design of the scheme and
the impact on the parking Arrangements
although amended plans have since been
received
um since these objections were submitted
and which reduce the scale of the
proposal
as detailed from the opposite report
the scheme was amended to reduce the
scale of the proposal to make it more
proportionate and appropriate within its
setting whilst the extension is large in
scale and the proposed material palette
would impart contrast with the existing
dwelling officers considered that the
proposal isn't of an acceptable scale in
design and appropriate within the
context of the site
concerns and regarding amenity are noted
but given the scale of the proposal and
the relationship to neighboring
Properties Plus the conditions proposed
is considered acceptable
the extension would remove much of the
space to the side of the property and
for parking and therefore there would be
a shortfall in the SBD three standard of
three spaces to two spaces however given
the there is parking within proximity of
the site and two parking spaces on the
site is considered to be acceptable and
not result in a severe impact on the
highway Network therefore officers
considered that the proposal does comply
with the development plan as a whole and
subjects the conditions in your report
recommend approval thank you
thank you very much Miss Miller there
are no speakers on this item so uh just
looking to members of the committee now
who wish to speak on this
counselor Wilson uh can I just ask if it
was called in before the changes were
made was that correct
correct okay
um it looks to me like the the changes
have made a substantial difference and
all the the objections are also with
regards to the original
scheme is that correct some of them are
I think the objections from
I get this right in terms of the numbers
and in regards to number 19 because
there was an extension immediately
adjacent to number 19 which is the
adjoining property that that element has
been removed and but the side extension
is still
um adjacent to number 23.
yeah I mean with those those changes I
can't see a huge any major reason for um
for for rejecting this that or certainly
any reason that would that would stand
up to to scrutiny so I think I'd be
happy to to propose that we we accept
this
the recommendation
thank you councilor Welton councilor
wins down there uh thank you yeah I'll
be happy to second that we accept the
recommendation
um
there have been lots of changes made to
this major original plans on the advice
of our planning team as always I
understand the the objections that's um
and the concerns that neighbors can have
but I think they've all been dealt with
in the report
particularly with the removal of one of
the originally planned site extensions
for this to um to remove the mashing of
it so yeah I'm happy to Second the week
accept this thank you chair
thank you councilor Thomas
yeah thank you
um just a couple of concerns I have
regarding obviously regarding the
parking which was just explained it's a
rental property and it could at some
stage
um
become HMO on application potentially
and the bar is not planning uh
consideration on this application the
number of parties basically does concern
me and it is just inside the mppf and
all seven limits of
over overbearing and overshadowing of
sunlight so
I'm a little bit wary about it but there
are no planning reasons to
to vote against it so I will be
supporting it but I think that there are
concerns perhaps going forward
[Music]
thank you Council minutes
I'm glad that the scale that the those
aspects of it have been changed I think
it makes it much more acceptable I think
for me it's still
um the side of of how close that is to
the neighbor and the park the parking
actually was production of parking space
now I know that obviously there are
there is parking
um along the road
um and then nearby it's not it's not a
horrendous
um Road in terms of like hungry vehicles
are parked Etc but I do feel like it
will then add cars to the road and
um cause other problems so I I whilst I
understand it's not a planning there's
not enough planning reasons to to
propose a refusal I will be I will be
voting
um not in favor thank you
Welsh
thanks chair um
two-story side extension two-story rear
extension front porch extension
conversionable rooms demolition of
freestanding Gary's a lot of house going
in here and have a lot of Sympathy for
the resident next door in that Bungalow
call there on Sunday and uh didn't speak
to the lady but um I can see her concern
it's a beautiful location and uh and I
can well understand
um her concerns about the family concern
living next door but I I I
um
uh comes with somebody's looking ahead
and which I didn't think of and and
rightly so but
um in planning terms chair I think it's
just about acceptable so um I think like
someone said I'll be voting in favor of
the application if you like but not
supporting it uh thank you chair
thank you councilor Welsh
any of the members looking to speak
uh Miss Mill I wonder if you could just
address the point counselor Thomas
raised about the future prospects of
this becoming a HMO and and the impact
that would have thanks
any conversion to a HMO would require
planning permission because Trafford
have an article for that removes the
permitted development to change from a
C3 to a small HMO and if they were to
apply for an HMO we would then consider
kind of the parking impacts of that and
any of impacts arising from amenity
[Music]
thank you against Thomas yeah there is a
concern there is a a process where
contracts in in my ward have been issued
to uh I also is going through an
application I believe to become a HMO
and they've already he's already become
a general that's that's my concern that
they could set things in stone and apply
later which uh or they can set the HMO
into practice and then apply for it
later on down the line after contracts
have been signed with tenants I think
perhaps a condition I don't know whether
we could put a condition in saying that
before any any form of HMO is considered
that an application has to be passed
before contract sign I don't know
whether we're allowed to do that
generally but that was my concern there
is there is a home
of multiple occupancy in our in my award
at the moment that went ahead and signed
contracts before application was granted
I don't think it has been as yet so I
don't want to be any more clear in that
or stay vague on that
thank you again so much I'm guessing
that would be a clinic enforcement
matter but I'll just chat with Miss
Miller
the condition would be unreasonable for
us to apply I I do
um understand your concern though and
just because contracts have been signed
planning enforcement is still available
and for review so if another price
change of use did take place we could
still investigate and ask that they
regularized the development and then
take action as such
noted on the condition and I believe
that there is an investigation but that
was the the time frame and that's what
concerns me
thank you Council Thomas
um so it has been moved and seconded
that we
um Grant planning permission in
accordance with the officer
recommendation so I'm going to move to
the vote on that now so all those in
favor of um granting planning permission
please
okay and all those against please
[Music]
so that application uh that motion is
carried so Prime permission is is
granted for that application thank you
so we'll move on to
um
our third item now which is
application 109 301 which is Brooklyn's
dragons uh JFC Sports Pavilion and we'll
have another introduction from Miss
Milner thank you
thank you the application relates to a
single story Sports Pavilion set
adjacent for football pictures that form
the Brooklyn's dragons
um junior football club set within a
predominantly residential area although
is um adjacent to Lime tree Primary
Academy school
and the application proposes extensions
and alterations to the existing
Clubhouse and includes also a footpath
um across the north of the fields
connecting the clubhouse towards the the
parking off bedof road
and the application is reported to the
planning committee as it has received
more than six of representation
representations contrary to the officer
recommendations the primary concern of
the representations is the parking and
access off Sunningdale Avenue and the
potential noise and disturbance caused
by the clubhouse and as detailed from
the airport the parking is provided off
budworth road
um and is limited on site although there
is a arrangement with the adjacent
School site that out of the school hours
they can use the parking however there
are no change changes to propose to the
parking as part of this application no
highway safety concerns have been raised
by the lha nor the environmental health
officer subject to conditions as
outlined in the poll report
the proposed changes to the clubhouse
are considered to be of an acceptable
scale in design and do not compromise
the use of the adjacent Sports pictures
with no objection from sport England The
Proposal would improve access to the
clubhouse and provide better
accessibility facilities within it
whilst the site does not provide on-site
accessible parking given there are no
changes to the parking and this is
considered beyond the scope of this
application and balanced against the
improvements to the access to the
clubhouse and within the clubhouse this
is considered exceptional
overall The Proposal is considered to
have an acceptable impact on design and
appearance and subject to the conditions
and acceptable impact on residential
amenity and as such is considered to
record with the development plan for
Trafford and is recommended for approval
subject to the conditions thank you
chair
thank you Miss Miller and there's no
speakers on this item either so uh
councilor Thomas I will come to you
thank you
um I love things like this I think that
sport is a
integral part of Trafford going forward
and
I've got massive Sympathy for the
residents of swimmingdale road because
this will occur at every single Sports
ground virtually in Trafford and
probably nationally that people are not
using the school's parking which has
been explained is provided to the club
which you know they should be grateful
for but I also don't think that the club
are doing enough in terms of making
people
prefer the school parking because
probably the distance it is to the
clubhouse
um I would like to see that they perhaps
have notices or have the gate closed at
an earlier time than closure uh to
Sunningdale Avenue
um there are pitfalls of that because of
disabled access but again there will be
a new pathway which hopefully will
incorporate better accessibility
whereby people will park away from
Sunningdale road but uh the parking is
object there now this isn't going to
make it any worse or any better unless
the club themselves take action in doing
it so I'm more than happy to support
this application
thank you Council Thomas councilor uh
councilor Proctor I'll come to you next
thank you thank you Chad it's just a
question
I thought that
um car Parks had to have a minimum
amount of accessible parking spaces
so can we not impose that as a condition
foreign
the parking isn't part of this
application and the existing car park
within the signage red is not a
demarcated car park it's not a um I'll
show you in the photographs so it's this
car park here they're at the on the
adjacent School site there are um
accessible spaces
um but that is for the school well
that's for the school in school time so
there are accessible spaces they're just
not very close
thank you
thank you counselor and Stanley
uh thank you chair pick up on both the
two previous speakers have said I uh I'm
also very much in favor of this
um the the parking issue already exists
this will make it neither better nor
worse but there will be oh and I also
look at the plans with great
care and detail to see where you could
get some more accessible parking spaces
in and you can't there's without asking
them to rebuild the car park
you can't ask there's nowhere to put
them but then but the reason why I
um balance that against the other
improvements and accessibility is the
plans will put an accessible uh toilet
into the new building and there will
also be a pathway built from the
existing car park so that you'll be able
to get from the what I call it a car
park the the
um the non-treated surface being used as
a car park you will be more easily able
to get from that to the um to the
clubhouse so I'm happy to support it
though if any other members of the
committee are clever than I am can work
out a way to get accessible parking
space into this I'd be very happy to
hear it thank you
do you not just paint the lines
it's surely it's that simple
no well I think um I think it's the
first graph illustrates it's not a
surface car park I don't think is it so
um
you could paint the lines but they're
just they just wear away and so this is
where I got to really I mean
it it doesn't provide a compliant level
of accessible parking but
um we can't force the developer to
do more development as proposed so we
can't force the developer to resurface
that car park paint it and provide
accessible spaces and I think um so we
could I don't think we could reviews it
might be we couldn't refuse permission
on that ground
and also
with the arrangement they have with the
school which does have two accessible
spaces
it wouldn't really deliver an
accessibility benefit that was sort of
more than marginal really
um and and so yeah I mean I agree with
with councilor win Stanley when you
balance that against the other
improvements in accessibility both
within the clubhouse and around the site
I think I think it that wouldn't be a
reason to refuse
um
you know the best place to have the
accessible parking will be near the
clubhouse but then you don't get the
impact on Sunnydale Avenue which um
which you've got to wear in advance
so I think I think condition 10
might address what the point you raise
councilor Thomas and as I understand
that it so they the gate on Sundale
Avenue
will be locked except for certain
purposes and
so does that mean there will be no
pedestrian access so would that defeat
the problem of people parking on Sundale
Avenue and then trying to use that gate
so the issue that you're grappling with
now was I think came up
decades ago and there is that a
condition that has been followed on from
several applications here so it's a
historic condition which we're
reapplying it does allow for some
pedestrian access but there's also a
noise management plan so we might tweak
that condition just to incorporate
measures to do with the the gate
operation as well
um but yes it is a long-standing and
condition to prevent it just being used
as a general access gate
sorry counselor Thomas I think you're
just following on for that can we add a
condition where the club uh be deemed to
introduce signage to dissuade people
from using Sunningdale I think it's it's
the problem with these clubs is the
space is few and far between to have
this this whole facility and there has
to be some kind of meshing with the the
community around it that probably on
Sunningdale Avenue A lot of people
benefit from
um it's just about get getting everybody
to work together to find a have a medium
you're never going to get a perfect
thing here with parking because I'll
have a tournament where everybody will
flood into the air and Roads from
everywhere will be flooded it's just
about trying to
meld them together in a way that they
can work together and get the best
possible outcome
thank you I've smelled that we can tweak
the noise management condition to talk
about signage or at least kind of
communication with members and visiting
clubs so we can look at something there
okay
it's good
thank you councilor wealth
uh I just wanted to celebrate the fact
that this will bring some some much
needed to secure cycle storage to the uh
to the club which I think is uh
um should be beneficial it doesn't say
how many spaces there will be but I
presume that that will be worked out
appropriately in the
um
it's in the conditions
thank you Council Welton yeah there is
there is reference to it in the
conditions I think yet
um
and it against the Welsh thanks yeah
just Echo what councilor Thomas says
just feels like there's an opportunity
for the club to talk to the people in
Sunningdale and get everybody you know
working together it just seems so
obvious you know
we say this a lot a planning committee
you know neighbors should talk to each
other when they're proposing things it
seems only common sense but very it
doesn't happen but I think there's a
there's a way forward here it's not
difficult to find thanks chair
thank you any other members looking to
speak
no so uh I think it's been moving
secondly that we approve I think
councilor Thomas you moved uh the new
second Council walls yeah
um
what's up
I think yeah sorry I was taking that as
read but I remember's happy too with
Miss Miller's proposal to tweak the
condition around the Knowledge
Management to um
encourage the club to to make sure
residents are not um users are not using
that gate yeah okay so uh so with that
condition
suitably tweet we'll move to the vote on
the um
proposal to Grant planning permission so
um
if all those in favor of granting
permission could indicate now please
okay thank you and that is unanimous
thank you so that application is granted
thank you everyone we'll move on now to
the last application we've got on the
list which is um
application109937 uh Friars Court uh 10
part driving hail and we'll have an
introduction from Miss Coley thank you
thank you chair
um first of all an update on this
application which is also in your
additional information report since the
publication of the committee agenda the
applicant yesterday lodged an appeal
against an undetermination of the
application to the planning inspectorate
and has requested the written
representations procedure the submission
of an undetermination appeal has removed
the ability of the council to determine
the application and that decision now
lies with the planning inspectorate
however the remains in need to determine
the council's position to adopt for the
forthcoming appeal consequently the
recommendation has been updated in the
additional information report to minded
to refuse in contesting the appeal but
remains on the basis of the reasons for
refusal set out in that may report
additionally one additional
representation being received not only
following the publication the main
report but also the publication the
additional information reports I'll need
to summarize that verbally it comes to
the property to the north of the of the
site La Petite boy
um so they welcome a new house but not
in the form the proposals have taken to
date letters of support have been
actively requested and come from
properties further away they agree with
the officer's report except in relation
to the impact on their property
the existing house is proportionate to
the size of the site and the new house
would be over 2.3 times the size of the
existing taking away the feeling of
spaciousness from the area and between
their dwelling and the current garage
the new dwelling would have a
significant visual impact on their
windows and the officer report does not
take into account the changing levels
between the properties there's concern
that any new planting or existing
planting would not flourish due to lack
of light from the new dwelling and the
height in the new dwelling would
obstruct the right of light both from
south facing Windows into the solar
panels and could cause issues with their
green electricity generation
um
so in terms of the introduction to the
application the application site relates
to a caller plot located on a junction
of Park Drive and Park Avenue in Hale
site is currently occupied by two-story
detached dwelling which is which is not
occupied
this application seeks planning
permission for replacement dwelling
which will be built over three stories
plus basement accommodation the dwelling
will be constructed in Brick elevations
with plantar Timber detailing and a
hipped tiled roof a link garage is
proposed to one side along along with a
driveway the principle of the loss of
the existing building which is not
identified as a positive contributor in
the conservation area appraisal is
acceptable it's replacement with the
dwelling of this particular
architectural style which is Cheshire
Revival is also acceptable in principle
however the scale of the massing of the
development is considered to be too
great and will be overly prominent and
dominant on this plot it would not
reflect the spacious character of the
conservation area which is key to its
significance as a Heritage asset the
detail design of the dwelling in terms
of its fenestration the proported
elevation is also not considered
satisfactory and will not reflect the
high quality architectural detailing in
the conservation area which contributes
to its significance similarly the timber
fencing proposed to the boundary does
not reflect the historic boundary
treatment present within the
Conservation Area
less than substantial harm has been
identified to the South Hale
Conservation area which is a designated
Heritage asset the only public benefit
which has been identified as a small
economic benefit during the construction
period which would not outweigh this
harm
is advised how their concerns could be
addressed however the applicant has not
been willing to make the Amendments
necessary such that the application
could be recommended for approval
the proposals conflict with the
development plan relevant policy in the
mppf and the council's adopted
Conservation Area management plan it's
therefore recommended that members
resolve that they would have refused the
application had they the opportunity to
do so thank you
thank you Miss Colette Aaron no speakers
on on this item so um just looking to
members of the committee who want to
speak on this
I see nothing wrong with this there are
houses on Park Drive that are far larger
the fun guns are far smaller
um there is massive support from in the
locality is going to provide very
a very substantial property for somebody
to to live in replacing less substantial
property that nobody's living in at the
moment
um
the street scene as such is when you
take into account the individuality of
most of the houses on Park Drive
um isn't really affected yes it is a big
property
but there are mitigations in the in the
front in the front line they're taking
away an old garage basically building
over an old garage and a Rockery that's
there at the moment The Lawns are
staying the same as Gardens to the side
the height difference isn't massive and
the to the rear of the property the the
fir tree sustained if we were voting it
I would I would be voting to support the
application
[Music]
thank you Council Thomas councilor
Welton
I have to say that I disagree I think
the
um I think it is very very large in the
you know it's been I pretty much agree
with with what our conservation officer
has has written in
um and has been put in the report
uh and I think we have to also we have
to back our offices up sometimes you
know in in these things it would be very
very easy to Grant this
um you know there
as we've heard that there is some
support in the local area there's only
um one objection
um but at the same time
we have a conservation area we have
principles and standards that need that
needs to be adhered to and this
application clearly you know clearly in
the in the view of our conservation
officer
um doesn't and causes harm to the
conservation Conservation Area there is
definitely a design out there that I'm
sure that their Architects would would
be able to create that will make a
beautiful large property on this site
but doesn't have the harms that that
have been pointed out by the
conservation officer and I think we need
to be strong and you know and stand
behind the offices in this you know in
in this situation
um and and you know and back them up and
say look there is harm and you you can
come back with a with a proposal that is
um you should be coming back with a
proposal that that deals with those
harms
um and so I will be
um
uh voting to refuse this or I would be
would be if it wasn't going to appeal
anyway thank you thank you councilor
Wilson councilor win Stanley
uh thank you chair
um I think this is a this is a a
marginal one there's a lot of Truth in
what the officers report says and I
agreed with many of those puts and I'm
going to be willing to listen to the
rest of this debate but what made me
come down
where I am now is coming down to agree
with the officer's report is really the
behavior of the applicants because they
were given advice throughout the course
of this as the changes they would make
which would make this acceptable to the
officers and acceptable to our planet
Earth to the um the planning team and
they made some of them and decided not
to make the rest of them and I find that
in really odd behavior
um and it added to this feeling was the
fact that was it yesterday or the day
before
when they knew the planning committee
they decided to appeal on the grounds of
non-determination it's a bizarre
decision
and it looks to me like they are playing
games with the with the planning process
I don't understand why they're doing
this that's what their beers will be
doing I mentioned this this is not the
reason why I'm proposing that we turn
this down I'm proposing that we turn
this down for the reasons I was laid out
in the in the report thank you chair
thank you councilwin Stanley uh
councilor Welsh
uh chair I'm going to agree with
councilman Thomas I I went to to look at
this and um
I've I've looked at the plans and um
there's actually a similar house across
the road and um
I can see what where the offices are
coming from they want to protect
um if I can say the history of that area
and we're going to be turning this house
around on itself so it'd be facing
um in a different direction in
completely opposed to the houses next
door door to it
um
but I really don't have a problem with
it and I agree with the officer when
they said it hasn't substantially
changed since the previous application
looked at the drawings and the the
differences were marginal but I think
the officers decided that application
but if if that first one had come to me
I would be saying that that the site
could take it it is a huge site
um and I really don't think it's going
to cause the harm
that the officers genuinely think and
the house that's there at the moment is
certainly causing harm because it's it's
not a pretty at all so um I'll if it
comes with Thomas wood we can't propose
in second hit but I would be supporting
councilor Thomas with this application I
would be supporting him and going
against the officers thanks chair
thank you Council Walsh any members
looking to speak
I think oh councilor minisco
all right
um I was going to say it's difficult
because the thing is my Council Walsh
says the site can take it I think the
thing the thing that makes you the only
really the only thing that makes you say
no is is that the Heritage
um you know aspect the conservation area
and I think when you've got on it you
know if it wasn't a Conservation Area
then they say yes fine go for it but I
think that's the one part where we do
have to have we do have designated areas
where we try and keep them you know keep
certain aspects for of those areas and
that there's a reason why we do it so I
think I would be actually on balance in
the end voting
um to to refuse it
um but um on grounds of Heritage really
in Conservation Area
um otherwise yeah that the site is big
enough to take it
um and it's not exactly a terrible
design or anything either
um so you know but I think the
conservation area is the reason why not
thank you
thank you Council Minister thank you
chair
I'm on um Google Street View and I'm
looking at number five on this road
which is a completely modern house it's
got
a big white and glass square in the
middle of it
um it's got
pale yellow
Timber clad walls and
it's not
it doesn't fit in the heritage site it's
absolutely gorgeous
but it's like okay this house got
planning permission at some point
and
and it does not fit in whatsoever it's a
it's a modern house
and
what's there at the minute is terrible
and it's clearly been allowed to fall
into rack and ruin so it can be
demolished
um
almost anything will be better than that
I think that's too big
yes it's it's a big plot of land it's on
but that will take most of the plot of
the Latin in comparison to what's there
already so I don't have an objection on
the style of the house
I it's size and massing it's it's
too much
and I'd much rather have number five
thank you Council Proctor yeah I mean I
think there are there's a variety of
houses in the area and um uh
uh and and so I don't think that is a
defining characteristic of the
conservation area the conservation
everything is around you know
acknowledges that they're um
acknowledges that there's a variety of
architectural Styles in the area I think
um
this has been alluded to it's around the
spaciousness of the plots and um
you know I think I sometimes I think
these applications are tricky because
obviously we all represent parts of the
bearer and in some parts of the bureau
you know this this development you know
would would seem not particularly
intensive but we are looking at this in
the context of the uh enhancing the
Heritage Asher enhancing the
conservation area and
um so I do agree with what councilor
Welton said I think this is over
development of the site
mainly because of the the layouts that
it's you know one long width across
across a particular part of the plot and
it because it's a corner plot I think
that probably has some flexibility about
how you would orientate a house that
you're going to develop there
um but for me it's to do with where it
is on the plot and the overall width of
it and it's perfectly possible to build
you know a sizable house on that plot
that retains the features of the
conservation area so
um if we were determining this I would
be uh voting to agree with those
officer's recommendation to to refuse
uh any other members looking to speak
so uh
together
um
so I think it's it's been moved and
seconded that we uh that we Grant
permission against office recommendation
I'll be minded to do that
um but it has been moving seconded that
we refuse so we'll take the refusal
first sorry tip we'll take the grant
first because that's contrary to the
recommendation so
um all those in favor were we too
be determined in this who would be in
favor of granting the application
contractor
recommendation if you could indicate no
please
okay and all those who would be against
okay so that is uh not carried so we'll
go on out to the motion to uh reviews so
all those who won't be binded to
uh reviews all those in favor of refusal
okay and those against the refusal
okay so that is Carriage so
um
we will advance that that reason for
refusal um in the appeal so that's the
end of that uh application thank you and
I don't think we have any items of
urgent business to consider so that
brings the meeting to an end and uh
we'll close matters there thank you
everyone